Nếu như mùi sấu và mùi chiến thân tư một số tiến đường trung tâm thành phố chiming sẽ tạm từ lưu thông,
nhằm phục vụ trường trình dức đốc lễ khai mặt đại hội thế giục thế thao thành phố lần thứ nhất,
năm 2018, theo phòng cạnh xác tông công gàn thành phố chiming việc nhiều trình dấu thông,
nhằm bảo đam chất tự ăn toàn trong quá trình tổ chức sự ghét. Quả đồng ghi hình dức đốc,
dân ra từ 20 hài dờ ngày mùi sấu tháng tư, lễ dức đốc chính thức dự kiến tổ chức lúc 20 hài mùi vụ,
ngày mùi chiến thân tư. Lồ chính giữ đốc xuất phát từ bảo tàng của chiming đến nhà dòng
đi qua các tuyến vinh tất thành cầu khánh hội tốn đất thắng tổ bà sòn. Lường era mùi hai,
lê sấu, an lường mùi hai và ký thúc tại cung viên bởi sông xe gòn. Chúng các khung dở tổ chức
lực lượng trình năng sẽ tạm thương phương tiệt lưu thông trên nhiều tướng, giọc lộ trình như trên
gồm các nhoạn tục đường vinh tất thành khu vực giá cầu khánh hội đường tốn đất thắng,
nhánh dẫn cầu bà sòn, cầu bà sòn và các tuyến đường giãn vào khu vực công viên. Phong cẩy sát dầu thông
khuyến cáo người dân chù đốc lượng trọn lộ trình thải khí phu hợp, chá thành hương dẫn của lực
trình năng không dừng đổ dưới lòng đường để tránh gây uống tắc dầu thông.